hey everyone
we are going to be reviewing
pixar's newest film called soul
it was just released today on christmas
of 2020 on disney plus
the link is in the bio below to check it
out i'm a massive
fan of pixar
i believe that they are
at the world's cutting edge of
edutainment education and entertainment
mixed together especially given
animation
so they in many ways are my role models
for the way that i want to
drive our own
content and help people
pierce the veil of reality and recognize
the kingdom of god within them
and the truth of non-dual awareness
and especially driving this style of
pedagogy for consciousness creates
reality into kids
so they can become
the most self-realized and
self-actualized
at the youngest ages possible so
they're a massive inspiration given the
pedagogy
that i will be along with our team
disseminating across the planet and so
this is very dear and near to my heart
and i love
the pixar team and i
am a huge fan of inside out which is
what they
made in 2015
which was an incredible
display of talent of not only animation
and production talent musical talent but
also
understanding it from a very
psychological level and disseminating
that to kids and adults to
help them understand what goes on in the
human psyche
and similarly with soul what you'll see
is it's that similar combination
of a very large amount
of depth with animation and music
and production but also with
the science and spirituality synthesized
together
with incredible interweaving with
storytelling
so just the disclaimer here
if you have not seen
soul yet i'm going to be walking
through the plot and providing
commentary
so if you would like to go watch that
first go ahead
uh if not no problem i'm gonna be giving
my commentary on it
and so i'm really looking forward to to
doing this with you
so to start things off pixar soul takes
a very macro
level view on life and the nature of
reality
obviously you can tell with the title
soul what we're doing is we're really
sort of
trying to boil down what it means to be
human and what a soul
means and
what it means to undergo the process of
a soul's preparation to incarnate in the
body and actualize
some sort of goal as well as the
souls
process and all of the
nuances in that journey which we'll
unpack here so again great graphics
visuals
ray tracing and story and this is
something that
is going to become more and more popular
in the future is sort of
these three spaces where you can
bring a camera into them and create the
animated environment
and then have ray tracing happening and
all these incredible
unreal and unity
engines that enable this type of
animation and production so this is a
massive part of our future
the main character's name is joe gardner
and so joe is
a middle school band teacher but he's
had a
deep amount of of
desire to get a larger music role
and so he
got an opportunity to undergo a
role with a quartet in performance
and so he showed up and he performed
really well on the piano
and they said excellent you have the
role for tonight
and so we'll see you at seven o'clock
for the show
and so he is super excited about that
he he's running on the streets this is
in new york he gets very distracted
and then he falls into a
sinkhole for uh in the sewage
systems and he dies
what you see is you see his his soul the
next thing you see is you see his soul
enter into this environment here
and so what you see here is you see this
sort of
you know this very bluish tealish
representation that's very cloudy and
dreamy
of what they depict a soul with a very
large
head and a smaller body it's very
fascinating how they decide to go with
these things
but he finds himself on this elevator
going towards this white
source light and it's fascinating that
they chose this white
source light as what home is and they
called that the great beyond
right and so there's about 150
000 deaths on planet earth that happen
every single day
and so you can literally hear you know
it goes something like
like that's how fast
people are dying around the planet and
so that's how fast this
the soul is being absorbed into that
source light
and the birth rate is
quite a bit faster than that about two
times faster than that
for births around the planet we'll get
to that in a moment but i find it
fascinating that spiritually speaking
that they chose this white source light
as where the souls
return and that it's very
uh indicative of many of the planetary
mystic traditions
it's a very spiritual and perennial
wisdom from them
and there's also a lot of
synthesis with physics there because we
talk a lot about that source white light
refracting in a prism and then creating
all of the different
combinations of realities of which this
is just
one with this sentience
vehicle that we find ourselves in so
there are many more creations with many
more
vehicles for consciousness or awareness
or sentience to immerse itself into to
explore an infinite amount of
phenomenology and that is what god that
is what source is that is what we
are and so it's very interesting that
they chose that so now
you know joe finds himself on a
on this conveyor belt that's moving
towards the white source light and he
just got that gig
right being a middle school band teacher
that is now give
getting this opportunity finally and so
he dies and so he's
trying he's anxious and he's trying to
avoid this conveyor belt to that source
light
and so he runs as fast as he can
backwards backwards backwards away from
it jumps off
and he gets to this place
where there are these figures
like you can see on the right and
they call themselves so interesting
they're uh
coming they say that they're the coming
togethers
of all quantized fields in the universe
and i believe they're called
jerry's and so and they're all called
that
and so i thought that was so cool
because
the coming together of all quantized
fields in the universe
it's very much a it takes a very
again a very perennial spiritual wisdom
and mixes it together with a very
physicalism
quantum mechanical wisdom and
in doing so it kind of takes and says
okay these
are literally all that is and it's cool
how they
created them here i think it's
fascinating
and so he finds himself here in this
environment where he
you know drops down from that conveyor
belt and what this is
is as we saw that we had that uh
that great beyond earlier this is now
the called the great before and so
what's going on in this great before is
this all these little
baby soaps and so these little baby
souls are basically
getting little patches on their
being that is getting them
ready to incarnate on planet earth
and they're undergoing this process like
training personalities
and it's not explicit about densities
which is a very
spiritual way of viewing it as in you
slowly undergo the process of kind of
training yourself from
a fundamental matter like earth
or water fire wind style
level and then you work your way up into
like plants and animals
and then you work your way up to human
in this third density
and then beyond that are sort of the
next densities
of love and light
and the gateway which is typically
referenced to ask something that is
recursive
and cyclical and that's why sir roger
penrose who won the nobel prize in
physics in 2020 believes in cyclic
cosmology
and the oroboros is the perennial
spiritual wisdom of the snake
that eats its own tail and so that is
very much so
what our realities are similarly like
and so it's very interesting that again
that there's sort of this
this process of the soul that in a sense
levels
up and in a sense that trains the
personality and gets
ready to jump through this earth portal
and so
what you have is you have this earth
portal and so once they get all of the
their
attributes these little patches that are
filled up
on their soul card if you will what
happens is that they become ready
to incarnate on the planet
and so again there's about two times as
many births happening on planet earth
than deaths per day
so again that's you know the birth rate
is like this but the death rate
is slower like that and so
now joe tried jumping through
into the earth portal but he couldn't
make it through because you have to have
the little incarnation sticker and so he
doesn't have that
and so instead he becomes a mentor
and so what mentors do
is mentors have this process and here
you can visually see that little
uh soul badge that i was talking about
earlier where they get those filled out
but these little soul personality traits
and so mentors what they do
is they sort of take them to two
different places there's the hall of
everything
in the hall of you the hall of
everything has literally everything on
planet earth that the
uh sole personality that's going to
incarnate can
explore and then they get one of those
experiences from the hall of everything
that sort of sparks them and then gets
them ready or the hall of you which is
basically filled with the mentors
memories
and so the the baby soul personality
that's going to incarnate can
undergo a process of going into the
mentors
hall of you with their memories to
uncover maybe something sparks there and
so that spark
is really critical because it's what
enables the soul to get ready to
incarnate
and so there's the soul 22
and if i remember correctly it's uh
it's tina fey playing soul 22 and jamie
foxx playing
joe and so here they are you can see an
image of them there
where now soul 22 has been going through
for
i believe it was centuries without
incarnating because
soul 22 had people like mother teresa
and abraham lincoln and
nicolas copernicus and carl jung and all
these greats
sort of undergo this process of trying
to mentor soul 22 to find a spark
but soul 22 never found a spark and so
now joe's this what you see is joe's
hall of view
and these the hall of you kind of is
like your corner stones and so
this is a really important way of sort
of perceiving your own life right
so if you're 25 35 45 15
55 whatever age you are just try and
look like what have been maybe 3
or 5 or 10 or 15 different cornerstones
of your life
like for example for me publishing high
level perception my first visual
synthesis
book was a massive cornerstone of my
life moving
to the bay area seven eight years ago
was a massively profound monumental
moment of my life
moving to l.a this year was a massively
profound monumental moment of my life a
cornerstone
right and so if you can sort of see your
life
like these cornerstones it gives you
deeper insight into both who you
are and where you want to go and what
you want to make these cornerstones and
if you think about yourself like a
mentor that's going to be taking like
the next sole personality through
you want to have really cool strong
cornerstones
and so it's really important to get
yourself if you are in a state of
suffering or depression or pain or anger
of any sort
to undergo the perennial spiritual
wisdoms of
doing things like creating that pause
through things like your
breath which will enable you to distance
yourself
more and more from the negative emotions
and direct yourself
more and more towards peaceful happy
blissful joyful emotions
and then that enables you to achieve
more goals in your life and it enables
you to be more
like that god consciousness that you
naturally truly
are already that and so that suffering
perspective
is a very constrained perspective and so
it's really important if you want to
achieve cool cornerstones in you
throughout your life
to rapidly move yourself away from that
negativity towards more harmonic
states of being and so then they go and
so they have some
exploration in joe's hall of view and
then
they go to the hall of everything and
this is where
again where souls are exploring earning
that final spark
and you can see in that hall of
everything there's so many different
options there was basketball music
photography baking rockets president
there's ferris wheel there's that hot
air balloon there's the
whale in there there's lightspeed trains
there's
it looks like archaeology and
anthropology and all this type of stuff
and so
you have to remember that there's so
many different things for you to do in
this world and so it's important if you
think about it like a big buffet of
options for your soul personality as
parents
conscious parenting is about exposing
your children
to many different options on that
massive buffet of possibility and then
it's following that maria montessori
method where
you follow the child's interests of
where they're finding
uh interest in what they want to to
bring as a value into the world
and that's the idea is that the soul
knows
the heart knows and so don't
choke it out of the souls as they
incarnate in the world
and so they undergo this process of
explaining how the
zone is like flow
and that that is the space between the
physical and the spiritual
and that's fascinating that they ended
up
undergoing the
explanation of said phenomenon because
it is quote one of the most important
phenomena that
civilization talks about is when you
lose your sense
of time and you lose your sense of space
and you lose your
completely lose your own sort of
individuated self
and there in a sense is just a blissful
ecstatic state of performance
and it's incredible and so what happens
is that
we undergo a process where there's
many quote lost souls
in the world that are they visualize
in seoul in pixar soul as depressed
giants that are roaming around in that
environment that you see there
and it's basically these massive beings
that have all of these
in a sense i we like to use the analogy
these
they're like an onion with all these
layers of shell
around them and that as we were
describing before they're in a state of
depression or pain or anger
suffering or misery of sorts and that
that sort of lost soul has completely
forgotten their essence
and so what they explore in
in pixar's movie here is that they
bring this sort of team of
of mystics in that area that then play
music
and help the lost soul shed their shell
and become embodied and return to an
awakened state
and they use this example with a hedge
fund manager right here where you see
there's in that top photo there's a soul
that is
falling into the hedge fund manager's
upper back and then that
hedge fund manager right after that
happens
they awaken and they throw everything
off their desk and they say free
yourself
free yourself they sort of you know
undergo a conscious awakening of sorts
and ask
what am i doing with my life and you
know we
i specifically underwent that conscious
awakening myself
i underwent it once when i was
approximately
16 once again when i was approximately
19 once again when i was approximately
22 once again when i was approximately
25
i've went through so many of these what
am i doing with my life
sort of moments and i'm so grateful that
it's brought me to this point
because those were so profoundly
intuitive
and that there's like we were describing
there's this sort of
like psychedelic mystical entheogenic
ship
that is going around this depressive
lost soul area
and what they're doing is they're waking
up
the soul from its lost and depressed
state and so that's very
much so it's kind of funny that they use
this
analogy and metaphor because the
psychedelics the entheogens and the
mystics
are the ones that wake up lost souls
so much of the time and awaken them to
divinity to god consciousness to what
their true nature
is to infinity to eternity to eternal
bliss
peace and existence that they are
and so there's also a nice moment
where they explain that when you can go
too far in this
way of flow and being in the zone
or you can become too self-realized
spiritually
where you have absolutely no engagement
whatsoever in the
physical and when you do that it's also
very disconnecting and it can become
very uh
it can be a massive disconnection from
life
from embodied life
and bringing value to
life and expressing yourself
self-actualizing creating some sort of a
north star
engaging in this dream in god's brain in
a way that
is of a beautiful flower expressing some
sort of aroma
and so they have to make these little
meditative portals that little
crew of ship filled with mystics
that they have joe undergo this process
of focus
and so what it does is it brings both 22
and joe
through that portal into
in this case it was joe was laying in a
hospital bed with a therapy cat
and so joe went into the therapy cat and
number 22 went
into joe and so that was the first time
that number 22 had incarnated
and so 22 was saying things like i can
feel myself feeling myself
in this body on this hellish planet and
you know and joe's in the cat
and so joe's having this hilarious
experience being in the cat
and so they escaped the hospital and the
first thing that happens is that you can
see that this new soul incarnated is
having this
very sort of strange troublesome
experience
where they're really tapping into like
the noise pollution of new york city and
just the
insanity of having you know
10 million people right there in that
tiny area
and it's just excellent writing overall
um and number 22 adored
pizza for the first time and so again
having a soul that had never
incarnated that was uh
going under a very deeply profound
spiritual process from simply just
eating pizza
and then saying i'm not angry anymore
and that was curing the the being hangry
which was
funny and so they plan to recommune with
this mystic
so the mystic is in the physical that is
undergoing
a very flow state process twirling a
sign on a corner in new york
and so because of that they're able to
immerse themselves in the spiritual
because they're in that flow state again
and so what they're going to do is
they're going to go find that mystic on
the corner so that they can
uh re-commune for that opening because
they are in switched
bodies and so
they saw the band
remember this is all happening in one
day they saw the band and joe
is in his hospital gown
and so they saw the band while they were
trying to wave down a cab
and the band was looking at joe like oh
my gosh
what a crazy guy i can't believe we just
let this person into our quartet for
tonight
and so he gets a voicemail from curly
and it says
you know they're trying to she's trying
to replace you the lead singer
and that uh you have to show up
looking good early in order to keep the
gig
and so now they're scrambling to try and
make that happen
and there was this fascinating part here
where connie who was one of
joe's middle school
band students who was playing the the
trombone
she wanted to quit
but she was also his best student
and that it might actually be her spark
and
that she was having a conversation with
the with 22 who had accrued so much
wisdom
where they were basically going back and
forth saying that
that she really wasn't digging school
and that
they were talking about how the ruling
class core curriculus stifles a descent
and that's a very orwellian tactic the
oldest trick in the book and they were
bonding and so that's why
it was kind of easy for 22 being
incarnated in joe's body to sort of
engage with connie
at this moment once they had that
bonding connection
and then connie underwent this process
of you know standing up again while she
was playing and just
crushing it musically on that trombone
and so it appeared
like she was in flow and in bliss and in
peace
and then you know she ended up leaving
it might be her spark and that
i just wrote that my spark is
disseminating awaking awakening content
and that's no matter how many obstacles
which there have been many obstacles and
there will continue being in your
north star self-actualization journey as
well and even your self-realization
there will be but we keep going because
that journey is the destination
and that what matters most is how well
we walk through the fire
of this experience and so
this accountant that is in this
hypothetical way station between life
and death
finds that the person that's missing in
the abacus the soul that's missing
that left was joe and the accountant
goes inconspicuously immersed in earth
to find him
and i love how they said this they said
that uh
what this is is that this is a
theoretical
construct in a hypothetical way station
between life and death
which is a very beautiful way of
explaining it
it's a very theory and it's been talked
about for a long time
and it's this sort of hypothetical way
station
between life and death where souls go
in a sense to for a
period of time that's said to be
anywhere from just a couple seconds to
longer to undergo a process of getting
ready to
undergo their next incarnation on
whichever said
reality creation that
they choose to based on set goals and so
this is fascinating that we're now
exploring this it's a very
very profound important topic for us
and i'll mention that more here at the
end but so they're at this
barber shop because joe's
undergoing so 22 is in joe's body and
joe needs to
cut his hair but they undergo a process
where they mess up
cutting his hair because again joe's
incarnated as a cat
in this process trying to cut joe's
hair who is 22s incarnated in his body
and so they're in this barber shop and
they're talking and they're
undergoing this process of uncovering
some of these profound realizations
about life like you're born to do
something
but how do you figure out what it is and
what if you pick up
the wrong thing or someone else's thing
and people rudely criticize each other
to cover a pain of their own failed
dreams that happens all the time
in the internet bully sphere and so
we must do our best to recognize that
hurt people hurt other people
and to sort of do our best to lovingly
and wisely and gracefully engage
with that sphere and help do our best to
make it so that people don't hurt other
people so that people
awaken more to the true nature of our
unity of being in existence
our oneness and then they realize that
they would never hurt
themselves which is what the other is
the other is the self the one
infinite creator the god the source that
we all are
and you attain those realizations once
you get to more non-dual states of
consciousness
so what happened also that was very
profound was that number 22
in joe's body ended up talking to the
barber about something other than
himself and so in that case this is an
important realization which is basically
ask your barber ask your uber driver ask
the people
that are around you as you're around
them in your life
about their life and about other
things that interest them don't just
talk about yourself ask good questions
the quality of your life's the quality
of your questions it's like a muscle
that we have to use we have to probe
reality with questions
and that's a good question ask yourself
what is the nature of reality what is
the nature of my consciousness my
awareness my sentience
and get kids asking that question at a
young age so that they can undergo a
process of self-realization and
more efficaciously actualize as well
from the highest possible morality some
sort of a transcendent noble aim into
the world
and so this accountant
from that theoretical construct comes
down and is trying to
uh very incomp inconspicuously engage
in the reality to try and pull joe back
but saying things like nobody can cheat
the universe but the const
the the accountant accidentally snags
the wrong guy
and then says oh oh it's not your time
and then
brings him back and that freaks him out
and then i love this little message
which i think is really important which
is basically stay away from processed
foods because the guy was holding a bag
of potato chips
and that's an important little lesson
because
you think about it that that sort of
physical input that you take into your
body
both as air water food
is so critical and so even data
as an input is is really important in
the information technology
so all your inputs are super important
for your health your longevity your joy
your peace
and so there was this moment that i
thought was
also critical which was that
the number 22 who was
incarnated in joe's body was the first
time on earth
and that there was this profound moment
where there was just this event
from the from what is likely the subway
system in new york city
and that most people especially most
adults
end up in such a state of restricted
levels of consciousness and beingness
that they would never
even consider playing around for a
moment
on one of those air vents or just even
right now just
you know dancing it up moving it up beat
boxing
a little bit yeah beat boxing and
singing a bit yeah
and so you have to be able to to
freestyle
in life right you got to be able to do
fun
stuff and express yourself like a kid
and the more that you do that what
happens is you feel infinity which is
what children are born
as they're born as infinite
and then we put them under the
subscriptions of the matrix machinery
which then chokes infinity out of them
which is when they undergo a process of
seeking because they're like why am i
stuck in an ego
onion with a bunch of layers what's the
true nature of reality
and so what happens is slowly they
unsubscribe from all of the matrix
subscriptions and machinery and
propaganda and they peel back those
layers of identity
and they uncover their own awareness
sentience consciousness
is it it is god we are that we are
source we are the one infinite creator
and so it's beautiful sort of
realizing that they have this embedded
in
soul in the film and so
remember that the more that you express
yourself like child
infinity the more that
you're anchoring the profound
realization
within your body of our eternity bliss
peace
infinitude and so
it's a great story and it interweaves
very beautifully because
earlier that 22 had mentioned that joe's
suit was kind of tight
and they had earlier mentioned that
joe's mom is a tailor who doesn't
approve of his music gig
and so as 22 is bending down in joe's
pants
they tear and they have to go to
his mom's tailor shop pretty late
right before again they're about to
perform in the quartet
and so again the great story
interweaving this is a massive success
of production
teams that can do storytelling really
well
it's like in the the three-point weave
in in basketball that you do it's a
drill that you do
and you do these types of drills across
many sports you have to be able to weave
these stories if you look at any of the
greats like harry potter with jk rowling
that there's a tremendous amount of
character and story development that
weaves
so you have to think about that when
you're trying to create profound stories
as well
and so this sort of leads us into the
archetype of a mom that doesn't approve
which is fascinating it's a very common
one
and that they undergo this process
within the taylor shop where
joe says that music is my ikigai music
is my reason for being and it doesn't
matter
about paying bills that's nonsense in
comparison to this
guy this reason for being and it
inspired
his mom to not only tailor his suit and
to fix that but also
to give him his dad's old blue suit
and so he got the chance to connect
to his mom at that deeper level and you
can see in that bottom image that she's
actually
more understanding now of his soul
and his soul personality and his soul
angle
and that so he goes off
to that on his way to that
quartet and to that performance
and that they get caught by the
accountant and so that
that accountant from the theoretical
construct of that way station between
the
life and death uh pulls
both 20 22 uh as joe as well as
uh joe as the cat back into the
hypothetical theoretical construct
and to that sort of space where the
souls are
and so they undergo a process
of 22
getting the spark and 22 got the spark
where uh on earth and i'll explain this
in a moment on earth 22
underwent a process of you know as all
of the greats
tried to bring 22 to get a spark of some
sort
all these great geniuses for centuries
we're trying
22 as she was incarnate
on earth recognize that even just the
simplicity
the the essence of just beingness itself
is-ness existence itself was enough
that even just the beauty of the fall
in new york city was enough and that was
very profound and so
they noticed that 22 had got that spark
in an
earth pass but they were arguing about
how
the spark happened and so 22
gave the pass back to joe thinking that
she doesn't have a purpose and that
the quantum energy being
again that being jerry i believe says
that
the spark isn't just purpose or meaning
that's a symbolic human
creation but there's something that's
even deeper about the spark
and i thought it was interesting that
they called this soul because soul is
both
the energy of being
as well as the soul in the music that
they were playing
and so what happened was that
we sort of undergo this process where
he incarnates and he
uh undergoes the process of performing
the quartet
doing a really good job and then
uh realizing that you know the journey
is the destination which is the profound
quote by
dan eldon and that
after they do this profound performance
and
meanwhile 22 is back in that in that
hypothetical construct where
she feels like there's no purpose and
she's becoming more and more depressed
up there
and joe crushes it his performance in
the quartet
and then asks the lead performer he says
outside that
there's he was like that's it you know
we crushed it but that's it
i was waiting my whole life for this
moment
and again that's why the dan eldon quote
so important the journey is the
destination the soul's journey itself
is the destination where
she responds to him saying that by
saying the younger fish
asks the older fish where the ocean is
thinking that this is just water that
this is just life
but this is the big game and that's what
the older fish responds to the younger
fish that this is not just
water this is the ocean and that's a
very profound
again condensed wisdom because
even joe's joy and peace was gone
because he was thinking that that it's
all about that trophy getting to that
moment
i will be happy when i get to that
moment and that that again that's a very
perennial
spiritual tradition as well and it's
even becoming more and more perennial in
the psychological literature as well is
that
you have to identify that the journey
the actual process
itself of self-realization
self-actualization piercing the veil
remembering
your true self as the infinite creator
is
literally the entire point and so this
is the ocean
this is not just water this is the ocean
this is not just
life this is the profound divine
experience that this is
and they have so many of these great
condensed wisdoms in here he had this
sort of experience again where he was on
the subway back
and he was thinking man why is there no
joy why is there no bliss why is there
no
peace why is there no ecstasy and
childlike laughter of the infinite here
and so his greatest joy might have been
in helping 22 out
who nobody else could do
and so that's when he's sort of back in
his
joe's back in his apartment after
incarnating and doing super well with
the quartet
and and realizing that you know the
journey is the destination he's trying
to figure it out
and he recognizes that he takes out this
lump of things that
that 22 had collected in his pocket
which was
you know that obsession with the pizza
that was so good and that
there was that little bagel piece and
the little yarn
and the little van moving tabs and then
that little piece to the
maple tree that helicopter leaf that had
fell that i was
telling you about earlier which we'll
talk about a little bit more but he
recognized the infinity of a kid the
infinity
of the blissful presence
of a child-like awe
at life and that who's always
in awe at all things on earth
is the riddle to life again the infinity
of a kid
who's always in awe at all things earth
is the riddle to life
i can't say that enough the infinity
of a kid who's always in awe
at all things earth is the riddle
to life hold that child
like awe in infinity throughout your
entire
journey and it will literally feel like
every moment
is the destination and it's gorgeous
and beautiful in art and bliss and peace
and ecstasy
again that dan held in quote the journey
is the destination
the essence of living fully every single
moment such a profound wisdom
communicated by the
pixar team here and so
then he you know he's there and he's
wondering like
maybe that moment when 22 said maybe
walking or sky watching can be my
purpose and when joe
replied that's just everyday old living
and so he realized that oh my gosh 22's
purpose
is just to be is just to find that child
like awe
in earth and so he starts playing and he
gets into a flow state and then he
enters into the spiritual again into
that
hypothetical way station between life
and death
and so there he is again and
he comes back to help 22
become earth incarnated and so he
recognizes that oh
wow 22 is very depressed and now 22 is
one of those
depressed monsters in pain and anger and
suffering
and that needs help sort of peeling off
those onion layers
and that they're
explaining that spark isn't purpose but
it feels when you're ready to live
and that even that moment when that
22 was incarnated in joe's body and was
looking at the fall in new york city and
seeing those little helicopters
that are samaras
which are the winged seeds produced by
maple trees
helicoptering down and falling in her
hand
and all maples produce those that life
is the simple enjoyment
of samaras not trophies
life is the enjoyment of the
those simple beautiful life force that
we get from inhalations and exhalations
that it's that jazzing that flowing that
vibing on just the simple raw
life itself raw life force
is sachit ananda it's existence
consciousness bliss
and so they grab her
help her uncover the process that we
just described
where that was her spark her spark was
just that simple beingness and so
because of that she sheds those onion
layers from that depressive state
she walks back up to that earth portal
and everyone's there watching
and so they she has her patch that
enables her to incarnate
and so she jumps down with joe even
though joe is gonna
not incarnate and so there you can see
her jumping down and it's fascinating
because that little
you know that little patch is it means
that
the soul is ready to incarnate it's went
through the schooling that's needed
which is such a perennial spiritual
wisdom about
the soul incarnating to undergo a
process of getting itself
ready experientially to be a human
and so now it's going down and it has
that that
that guidance system that's happening
where
you know the soul is going to be
incarnating in a very specific
place on the planet that's going to
enable them
to express their unique essence
and so it's not an accident your
birthplace is not an
accident your birthplace is a very
spiritually
significant location that you actually
orchestrated yourself and that is
something that
the tibetan book of the dead is trying
to
illustrate for science right now where
they have these logs of the dalai and
punch and llamas
and incarnations and where they plan to
be
and sort of the the different things
that the the young soul
that has incarnated into the child that
has these reminders of their previous
lives
and so there's more and more work being
done in this space but your birthplace
is not an accident you
chose to be this exact
unique expression of god you chose to be
that
and you have to remember that you chose
to be that this is not an accident this
is not nihilistic
this is deeply beautiful artistic
we are god expressing itself infinitely
through
all of these different creations and
through all these different
unique expressions of individuals
and so we have to realize that
and share that with people and soul does
that soul does
the process of getting children and
parents to realize
that they are here for a reason it's
like the most
proper uh
like scientifically gentle way to ease
spirituality into the mainstream which
is very fascinating
and so they did a great job at it and so
the question is what will you do how
will you spend your life
i'm not sure but i'm going to live every
minute of it and
my take is that soul is our first
collective modern step at enlightenment
meaning that
it's a very mainstream way to try
and deliver the essence of the perennial
spiritual
teachings to the masses and in this case
you knowing that you are
that that you are that one infinite
creator that god that source that is
undergoing the process of all of these
different
unique souls that are undergoing some
sort of process of getting themselves
ready to incarnate and express
themselves
as that one infinite wisdom
and that's it's getting people more and
more excited
and ready and prepared for the more
enlightened and abundant and prosperous
future that all of our hearts know as
possible to live in this more
enlightened civilization
even in just the next 10 years we can
architect a much
more enlightened civilization that is
more
focused on meeting the basic needs of
all people and enabling more and more
people to undergo self-realization and
self-actualization and
and disintegrating the matrix constructs
that exist
that hold people's souls back and so
this is our first collective modern
step at enlightenment in 2020 it's a
beautiful
way to end 2020 with a big like
enlightened
pow that we so needed and so
i highly recommend you to watch seoul i
highly recommend you to watch
inside out if you haven't already go
watch those
so the link is in the bio below and also
we need to make more
animated relatable awakening content
like this
and that is what we are doing with
simulation
along with drawing the most influential
celebrities and influencers and people
to come onto our show to talk to us
about the nature of reality
non-duality consciousness awareness
sentience maximizing human potential
synthesizing science and spirituality
we're
also synthesizing all those concepts and
disseminating them
through animated series and through
other content
and pixar is a massive massive
inspiration to us and so we're super
grateful for the entire team
for making this happen over the years
that it took to get done
and the inspiration that this will have
for generations to come and it's super
relatable for millennials gen
z and generation alpha and beyond and so
this is a cornerstone this is a
masterpiece for our future
and we have to take the time to make
masterpieces like this to inspire our
collective
awakening and so you can see look at
this
long list of animators right look at
this long
list of uh simulators right
and just the sheer complexity that goes
into the process of registering with
motion picture association getting your
your
soundtrack done and undergoing all of
the process of making sure that this is
all
you know executed in the optimal way
possible
the directors with pete dr and kemp
powers
they had a budget of about 150 million
dollars to do this
and so just a very profound
important awakening
story film
super well done animations super well
done
production music
again the interweaving of stories
the
the ability to tie in a very profound
spiritual enlightening perennial
wisdom across the different mystic
traditions
and add that to modern day
science and storytelling as best as you
can and then
share that in a profoundly awakening
narrative
it's just it's a masterpiece it's a
masterpiece
and they have faith right science has
yet to be able to
art figure out how to investigate with
the scientific method things like
all these different flags that are
planted beyond the edge of what
humans know and so pixar took a leap of
faith
by talking about souls and that's
beautiful and i'm really grateful that
they're doing it and
everyone else that's a part of the
spiritual communities around the planet
should be extremely grateful for pixar
making this piece of content
that is enlightening our generation and
the next generations to come
it acts as a massive cornerstone and
masterpiece
for what the bar is
moving forward and so let's
shatter that let's keep making stuff
that's even more awakening and impactful
and inspirational than this
it's on our radar we're already doing it
we're already writing and producing it
and i encourage you to do the same
as well so thanks for tuning in to this
visual film review on pixar's soul
i would love to hear your thoughts in
the comments below on what you think
about pixar soul what you think about
this visual film review i would love to
hear from you
check out the link in the bio below to
go and watch it if you haven't already
go and give it a watch go watch
inside out as well another extremely
profound beautiful masterpiece of theirs
like the video subscribe if you haven't
already share the video with other
people that need to hear about the
importance of the soul
entering into the mainstream
nomenclature of our world
and getting more and more excited about
our collective enlightenment
and it's inching us towards non-duality
and inching us towards
god-consciousness the one infinite
creator that source
that we all are and that we've just
forgotten
and that we're piercing the veil to
remember the unity of all
finding all of us finding the kingdom of
god within us
and so it's beautiful this is happening
so again share this with people that
need to see it
and also support
the artists the entrepreneurs the
spiritual leaders the scientists
engineers in your communities and around
the world that are doing really
important awakening work you can support
us simulation all of our links are in
the bio below
and go and build the future manifest
your dreams into the world i love you
very very much thank you for tuning in
thank you pixar
incredible work with seoul thank you so
much for your leadership and pioneering
in this space
we will be carrying the torch even
brighter into the future you're a
massive inspiration to us
i love you so much thank you
thank you for this epic end to 2020
love you thank you
you